Now, when talking about the end-to-end argument, it
is worth remembering that the end-to-end argument is
just that. It's an argument. Not a theorem,
or a principle, or a law. And there are
many things that have come to violate the
end-to-end principle. Network address translators, which we'll talk about
in the next lesson, violate the end-to-end argument.
VPN tunnels, which tunnel traffic between intermediate points on
a network, violate the end-to-end argument. Sometimes
TCP connections are split at an intermediate
node along an end-to-end path, particularly when
the last hop of the end-to-end path is
wireless. This is sometimes done to improve
the performance of the connection because loss on
the last hop lossy wireless hop may
not necessarily reflect congestion, and we don't necessarily
want TCP to react to losses that are not
congested related. Even spam, in some sense, is a violation
of the end to end argument. For e-mail the end
user is generally considered to be a human, and by
the end to end argument, the network should deliver
all mail to the user. Does this mean that spam
control mechanisms are in violation of end to end and
if so are these violations appropriate? What about peer to
peer systems? Where files are exchanged between
two nodes on the Internet but are assembled
in chunks that are often traded among
peers. What about caches, and in-network aggregation? So,
when considering the end to end argument,
it's worth asking whether or not the argument
is still valid today. And, in what cases.
There are questions about what's in versus out,
certainly. And, what functions belong in the dumb
minimal network. For example, routing is currently in
the dumb minimal network, do we really believe
that it belongs. What about multicast? Mobility quality of
service. What about NAT's, and it's worth considering
whether the end to end argument is constraining innovation
of the infrastructure by preventing us from putting
some of the more interesting or helpful functions inside
the network. In the third course,
we will talk about software defined networking,
which in some sense reverses many aspects of this end to end argument.